To set a Matrix4 in creation, you can pass the values for the matrix in the
constructor function. These values happen to set the matrix to perform
translation, moving an object to the position 12, 16, negative 5. Note that this
initialization is purposely made to look like column major form. Where the
translation values are on the right. However, this order is not how the data is
stored in the matrix itself. Looking at the order here, 1, 0, 0, 12. You might
expect to see that in the matrix itself. But instead you see 1, 0, 0, 0. That's
because as we've pointed out before the translation values go at the very end of
the matrix as show here. Since translation is a common transform 3JS provides a
function to set a translation matrix called makeTranslation. You give the
position and it fills in the matrix for you. So say we have our robot arm, in
object 3D. To apply a matrix 4D to an object 3D, the most direct way of doing so
is to set the local matrix on the object itself, however you also need to set
matrix auto update to false. Remember that 3JS has its own transform system
built in. Position, Rotation and Scale. By setting matrix auto update to false
you say, don't use this, but use this matrix instead.